a roller coaster of new consumer
technology has come to Las Vegas with
thousands of companies showing off the
new the cool and the kind of weird
some will hit the market with a bang
others will be Duds I could run down for
you over the years all the different
trendy things that have been the next
big thing uh and then the next year we
come back and it's completely forgotten
about among this year's highlights LG
has a new wireless TV screen no more
messy cables the content is streamed
from a box that can be situated several
meters away the integration of tech into
the automotive World continues Honda and
Sony have joined together to create a
new company called aphila and which
they're going to make a brand new
electric vehicle that's going to have
the latest technology from Sony and
entertainment in sound quality in
cameras to make a really smart electric
vehicle BMW has an AI equipped model
that can talk to drivers and learn their
preferences and it changes colors to
suit your mood they could have
checkerboard patterns they could have
stripes if you want to have it blue one
day and read another you could do that
you could do whatever you like with it
augmented reality products are
represented at CES including these cool
headsets from U.S company magic leap the
metaverse is gradually taking shape
although no one really knows what that
shape will be and by the way where am I
sustainability is a theme at the show
John Deere has a hybrid electric farm
tractor there are electric motorcycles
bikes and scooters and even boats
developers hope to disrupt the maritime
industry what do you see here is the
navi a30 or in 30 as we call it is the
world's longest range electric hydropoid
and America's first electric car default
boat and the key part of this is that it
is 10x more efficient than traditional
gas bird and there are plenty of offbeat
or just plain cookie products on display
this Gizmo can scan your food and tell
you how many calories you're going to
eat this one can sanitize your hands
before dinner and this thing can
supposedly zap your brain and relieve
anxiety or other unfortunate mental
States no thanks I'm not putting that on
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Las Vegas